and people from the community continue
to show support for the victim tina
tintor a memorial is growing where that
crash happened joe mohler is at rainbow
and spring valley parkway with reaction
tonight joe
tintour's home is just a few blocks
north of where this crash happened here
at this intersection and tonight this
memorial continues to grow we just
watched a woman get out of her car and
drop off some flowers here for
tintor and her family many are sending
their condolences to our family
since he's a football player he can go
as fast as he wants and do what he wants
23-year-old tina tintour was a few
streets away from her family's home when
she died along with her dog according to
police henry rugg slammed into her suv
they also say moments before the crash
he was going 156 miles per hour in his
corvette i didn't think it'd be a
neighbor
anybody it's
close it's real close to home maria and
margaret orozzo live near the home of
tintor's family when we found out it was
a female with her dog
now finding out that she lives right
here
it's too close to it's
sad the district attorney did not
believe tintour was married or had kids
just hold your left was tight that's
just it hold them tight as flowers and
candles continue to be dropped off the
support for her family continues to grow
online many sending their condolences to
the tintors a family member at the home
told us they do not want to speak at
this time and will set up a fundraiser
again tintorn did live a few blocks away
from here although we do not know where
exactly she was headed she was going in
that direction reporting live this
evening joe molder live local now